froid polaire températures sibériennes
aucun adjectif me semble assez fort ce
soir pour qualifier la vague de froid
qui sévit actuellement sur notre région
- 20 à - 30 degrés la nuit
- 10° à peine dans la journée et cela
devrait se poursuivre en tout cas cette
semaine
ce froid inhabituelle est à l'origine de
nombreux incidents et là des
conséquences dramatiques pour les plus
démunis
malgré les dispositifs d'accueil mis en
place les cas de détresse se multiplient
surtout parmi les sans abri tumoraux
judor où je suis dehors habite lui vaut
tout autant pour sa cavale et pour la
mienne aussi
houle vis-à-vis celui qui les reee et
construit un petit cabane en bois en
palette de voix pour mouna moi j'y suis
sera désigné comme si celui-là ces deux
hommes ne sont pas les seuls à connaître
ce dénuement extrême
ils sont des dizaines des centaines
peut-être vivent dans des installations
de fortune sans autre protection contre
le froid que quelques couvertures donné
par le secours catholique ou emmaüs
ce ne sont pas les clochards
traditionnels ils ont épuisé toutes les
ressources des assedic ou de l'aide
sociale sans travail et sans toit il
cherche quand même à vivre le plus
décemment possible car ils n'ont pas
tous perdu l'espoir tout partout la même
crise
c'est le manque de boulot pas de travail
pas d'argent
qu'est ce que vous faisiez comme boulot
moi avant je fais de la cuisine du
cuisinier avait quand même vous
soupçonniez là à oui ça laisse pas
abattre ça y'a pas de problème je
voulais prendre à un studio à bon prix
auger je suis appelé trucs des domaines
et jarrod immobilière savez ce qu'ils
m'ont répondu que monsieur les mandalas
s'est dit que ça parte mais il faut une
fiche de paye
cela se débrouille les plus démunis
n'ont d'autre choix que de frapper aux
portes des centres d'accueil des
organisations humanitaires
sitôt qu'ils ont ouvert je suis venu
parce que j'en avais marre de rester
devant
c'est le premier parce que je vois
maintenant on a juste bien contents de
notre logis tom brady et la soupe le
soir et tout ça est le matin le café 1
ça fait du bien ça parce que la ligue tu
t'assures lire on vide greniers toute la
journée un candidat derrière notre coup
c'est pas comme will wright le froid qui
règne actuellement la c est vraiment la
panique on dit dans les déborder on ne
dispose pas cette place problème de
place problèmes de climat trop rude et
problème de génération en effet 75 % des
personnes accueillies dans ces centres
au moins de 35 ans
[Musique]